i think it's high time we start
exploring some buddhism on this channel
as many of you in the audience have
already pointed out it is after all one
of the largest religions in the world
and one that has a lot to offer when it
comes to
history beliefs and practices
as is always the case of course buddhism
is incredibly diverse with many
different schools and ideas and ways of
understanding certain teachings
much of which can take years and years
of study to understand
just like with hinduism we're not going
to be making some grand video called
what is buddhism
not only because it's so incredibly
broad and complicated but also because
several other people have already done
that made really great videos that you
can advise if you're interested in that
instead what we're going to do here is
we're going to dive straight into some
buddhist philosophy some
very significant schools of thought and
thinkers within that tradition
and try to understand what those schools
and those thinkers are
saying how they understand buddhism and
through that we can gradually get an
understanding of this vast and
incredibly
rich
religious and spiritual tradition
and there are few ideas associated with
buddhism as famous as the idea of
emptiness or shunyata
most associated with the incredibly
important buddhist philosopher nagarjuna
who teaches that all things in existence
are empty this is an idea that became
very influential in buddhism especially
in the branch known as mahayana but a
lot of people also tend to misunderstand
it or have trouble grasping what it is
actually saying
is it a kind of existential nihilism
claiming that nothing in reality exists
or is it more complicated than that
today we're going to explore the
teachings of nagarjuna and try to
understand his school of thought
[Music]
when people think of buddhism they tend
to picture things like ascetic monks
sitting in meditation often completely
detached from the world in a zen-like
state but what many tend to forget is
that buddhism has one of the most
rigorous philosophical or intellectual
traditions in the world which has
contributed immensely to philosophy in
general across history the various
buddhist philosophers have written some
of the most profound stuff and one of
the most famous if not the most famous
of these figures is the 3rd century
thinker nagarjuna he is often considered
the founder of a school known as
madhyamaka or the middle way as well as
the most important systematizer for the
idea of shunyata or emptiness and
through this he was one of the most
central figures in the development of
mahayana buddhism in particular
again buddhism is divided into various
schools and branches and while these are
many it is generally thought that there
are two or three main overarching
branches of the religion there is
theravada which means something like the
school of the elders and is the dominant
form of buddhism in places like cambodia
thailand myanmar and sri lanka then
there is mahayana which means the great
vehicle and is the largest branch of
buddhism being the dominant form in
places like china japan vietnam nepal
malaysia and many other places
sometimes vajrayana or tantric buddhism
is considered its own third major branch
while at other times it is seen as a
sort of part of mahayana buddhism but in
any case this school is most popular in
tibet and is the same as what is often
known as tibetan buddhism as well
all of these branches especially the
first two have various schools and
movements within themselves of course
but this is considered the most broad
and general division of the religion the
differences between the branches are too
many to cover here and it will hopefully
become more clear over time but in short
they tend to accept different
collections of texts as authoritative
have different monastic rules as well as
significant doctrinal and practical
differences and the subject of today's
episode nagarjuna serves as one of the
most important figures in the
development of mahayana buddhism in
particular and his ideas became the
foundation for much of that school and
the basis on which many later movements
were formed nagarjuna himself is an
elusive figure he's generally thought to
have lived between the second and third
centuries and in india there are many
different accounts of exactly when and
where he lived but of this general
outline we can be relatively certain
hagiography state that he came from a
brahmana family the highest caste in the
hindu tradition and that he at some
point in his life became a buddhist
in particular he eventually became
affiliated with the mahayana branch
which was a minority in the region at
the time and would indeed become one of
the key figures in the development and
later popularity of that tradition other
than this we can't say much at all about
his life other than that he was
obviously a very gifted thinker who
wrote works that would become classics
in the history of philosophy and
religion his most famous work in which
he argues for some of the most central
ideas associated with him is the mullah
madhyamaka karika a real mouthful of a
word that means something like root
verses on the middle way
this work was so influential that a
whole new school of thought within
mahayana buddhism appeared around his
teachings which became known precisely
as madhyamaka or the middle way and we
will see what this is referring to in
due time we will explore this work and
the thought of nagarjuna through two
major themes in his writings the idea of
shunyata or emptiness probably the most
famous idea he is associated with as
well as the doctrine of the two truths
which is another central teaching in
buddhism so let's get to it in short the
teachings of shunyata or emptiness is
kind of exactly what it sounds like it
states that all things in the world are
empty that is they are empty of
intrinsic nature or existence
there's nothing in the world that exists
intrinsically but everything is as i
said empty now you may be thinking to
yourself is this just existential
nihilism is nagarjuna saying that
nothing at all exists
many later
non-buddhist commentators and critics of
buddhism and nagajona have often
interpreted his teachings in this exact
way but this is actually not the case
this is a misunderstanding most most of
the time and what nagarjuna is saying is
actually a lot more complicated than
this but to understand this fully we
kind of need a crash course in some
basic buddhist teachings i'm sure many
of you know some of the basics of the
religion like the four noble truths for
example that teach that life includes
suffering or life is suffering
that
there's a reason behind suffering and
that suffering can end and then the path
or way to end that suffering the idea of
emptiness is part of a discussion
involving primarily two key aspects of
buddhism the doctrine of no self or
anata and the doctrine of dependent
arising
the buddha taught that there is no self
that the thing we think is ourselves the
thing we refer to when we say i is
actually an illusion
there is no enduring core or self in any
human being but only a collection of
different skandas or aggregates such as
consciousness mind and sensations that
we sort of put together into this idea
of a unified self that actually isn't
really there
this is a very important feature of
buddhism that essentially all schools
agree on and realizing it is considered
to be a central factor to reaching
enlightenment and nirvana connected to
this is the idea of dependent arising
this is essentially the idea that all
things in the world are dependent in
their existence on other things
everything is temporary and exists only
in dependence on everything else the
famous buddhist teacher tik nathan once
explained it beautifully through a
flower you may look at a flower and
think that it exists in itself and
independently but this is not true
try to think of that flower without the
soil from which it grows without the
sunlight that helps it grow and
illuminates it without the very space in
which it stands or without the
particular time in which it is there
suddenly you no longer have a flower at
all
and this is true of all things in the
world there is nothing that exists
independently all things are constantly
dependent on everything else for its
existence
even the parts that make up a specific
thing are in themselves dependent on
other things and the parts of those
parts are just the same this leads to
the conclusion that there kind of aren't
any things at all because all quote
unquote things we conceive in the world
are only a collection of various other
things that make it appear a certain way
at a particular time
and it is us who conceptualize that
thing into a false entity there is a
famous thought experiment or story in
buddhism that explores this question and
that is the story about the chariot in
what is known as king malinda's
questions in this story the king milinda
is having a discussion with a buddhist
sage called nagasena
the king asks the sage about the
doctrine of no self how it can be that
there is no such thing as the personal
self when that seems like a such an
apparent reality to everyone nagasena
points to a chariot and asks what is a
chariot
is the chariot in the wheels the king
answers no
is the chariot in the axles again he
answers no is it in the reins still no
is it in the seat the king answers in
negative to all questions regarding the
parts of the chariot including if the
chariot is simply the combination of all
parts
well the buddhist stage says if the
chariot cannot be found in any of the
parts then there is no chariot
the designation chariot is dependent on
all these various parts but in reality
quote-unquote chariot is only a concept
a name that is applied to something that
doesn't actually have independent
existence of its own
the self is the same way we say that
there is a self we talk about ourselves
using words like i even the buddha did
so because it is convenient and useful
in the everyday world but in reality
there is no such thing since it is only
a name that we give to a collection of
temporary aggregates
so these are some of the central
features of buddhism and which become
very important for the continued
discussion that we're having here today
basically all buddhists agree on the
basics of of these teachings but they
can disagree on some of the details and
interpretations so for example how deep
does the teaching of no self go does
this simply mean that there is no self
and basic things in the world have no
existence as such or is it even more
radical than that one collection of
buddhist schools that existed in
antiquity were known as the abhidharma
these were different groups that often
used philosophical speculation to fill
out some of the metaphysical questions
and details of the buddha's
teachings and these abi dharmikas are
important not only for the general
history of buddhist thought but also for
understanding nagarjuna and the
madhyamaka school
indeed in his most central work the
mulamadhyamaka karika nagajna
essentially spends the majority of the
text responding to ideas put forth by
the abhidharmakas and bases his
arguments often on refuting them the
abhidharma schools are varied and can
hold different ideas but in general they
believe that there is no enduring self
and that reality is characterized by
impermanence and dependent arisings just
like all buddhists the conventional
reality that we experience consisting of
things and events are only conventional
constructions and not ultimately real
there is no chariot as we saw just as
there is no individual self
anything that we experience is only a
conceptual construct of a variety of
factors and temporary happenings
none of these things are ultimately real
but according to the abhidharmakas there
is something called darmas which are the
ultimate constituents of reality
the dharmas are factors or phenomena
that make up all things and events
they are ultimately real although still
dependent on each other
the dharmas are never experienced as
individual things but arise through
dependence on each other and in constant
flux
but it is these fluctuating dharmas that
make up all of reality as we experience
it and we conceptualize all these
temporary happenings as individual
things like the self for example or the
chariots but what is important here is
that the dharmas are real
for something to be counted as real
according to buddhist philosophy in this
case one must be able to say something
ultimately true about them they need to
have an intrinsic nature something that
is inherently true about it in itself
independently
and the dharmas are that according to
the abhidharmakas the dharmas have
intrinsic natures and only one intrinsic
nature per dharma
and all these factors when interacting
with each other create the temporary
happenings that make up our
this is the general outlook that
nagarjuna is responding to in his great
work
and he argues very forcefully that this
perspective is mistaken and actually
fails to uphold the principles of the
buddha he instead takes a stand that
appears at first glance to be even more
extreme but which actually claims to
avoid extremity
he argues that there are no dharmas at
all
there are no things that are ultimately
real at all not even these fluctuating
basic components
there is nothing that can have intrinsic
nature and therefore be categorized as
real everything is empty
this is what is referred to when we talk
about the teaching of emptiness or
shunyata
to nagajona reality is characterized
entirely by emptiness all things are
empty of intrinsic nature and are only
conveniently conceptualized to be real
there can be no darmas or ultimately
real things and he argues in the text
for how these dharmas would in
themselves have to be empty and thus
that would mean that they lose their
status as dharmas to begin with so there
can't be any dharmas because dharmas are
empty just like all other things
quote there being no dharma whatsoever
that is not dependently originated it
follows that there is also no dharma
whatsoever that is non-empty
now as stated before many have taken
this to mean that nagarjuna affirmed a
kind of existential nihilism
many of his later critics like the
famous
vedantic
scholar sage shankara who writes a
couple of centuries later
is one example of that he often accuses
buddhists of being nihilists but this is
actually a misunderstanding of what
nagarjuna is saying here what he and the
madhyamakas are saying is not that
nothing exists at all but rather that
there is nothing that has an intrinsic
or inherent nature or essence right
there's nothing that has an independent
existence everything is empty everything
is dependent on everything else and
nothing has an intrinsic nature to it so
in that sense it's kind of true that
nothing exists because there are no
things to exist in the world there is
only the constantly changing dependent
arisings which in themselves are empty
but that doesn't mean that what we
experience isn't there
at all on an ontological level as we
normally understand it it's not complete
nothingness right emptiness does not
mean nothingness that's a very important
distinction indeed this teaching of
emptiness is a natural extension of the
buddha's teaching on no self and
dependent arising
there is no self no inherent essence to
anything because all things are
dependent on everything else for its
very existence
nagarjuna argues that this precisely
avoids nihilism and extremism as the
name of yamaka suggests it is a middle
path between annihilationism that things
don't exist or can go out of existence
entirely on the one hand and permanence
on the other hand that there is anything
at all that has permanence or is
independence in its existence and in the
mulan yamaka karika he argues for this
position in a very systematic way
through tackling the topic from every
conceivable angle using logical
deduction
nagarjuna makes it clear that according
to him the teachings of the buddha when
one considers them properly must lead to
the conclusion of emptiness but one
needs to be careful here not to consider
it a statement of ultimate reality in
itself either shunyata is a useful tool
to collapse all ideas about objects with
inherent natures but it is not an
ultimate truth about reality in itself
emptiness is not the quote-unquote
nature of things in that way
quote emptiness is not some kind of
primordial reality but a corrective to a
mistaken view of how the world exists
to nagarjuna there are no ultimate
truths at all or rather there is no
ultimate reality not even emptiness
indeed emptiness itself
is empty
quote dependent origination we declare
to be emptiness it that is emptiness is
a dependent concept just that is the
middle path
after all for emptiness to be a thing
there needs to be things that we deem to
be empty but as we saw there are no such
things because everything is empty and
without intrinsic nature which means in
the final analysis that emptiness itself
is empty because it itself is dependent
on things
which in themselves are empty
does your head hurt yet
it's some trippy stuff that can be hard
to wrap your head around but to
understand mahayana buddhism in general
and all of the later movements that came
after nagarjuna we kind of need to at
least somewhat understand what he is
trying to say
if you are an inquisitive person you may
have started asking yourself questions
like what does this mean for some of the
basic principles of buddhism
like for example nirvana or samsara and
reincarnation or karma and all these
different things
are these things empty and ultimately
not real too
the answer is yes indeed they are but
here it is important to introduce
another one of the key features of
nagajuna's thoughts and that of a lot of
buddhism generally which is the doctrine
of the two truths
in simple terms this is the idea that
there are two essential ways of
approaching reality conventional truth
and ultimate truth
just like a lot of other buddhist
principles this has been interpreted in
different ways by different schools but
to nagajona it is connected to the idea
of emptiness
we can either look at the world through
conventional truth that is through the
concepts and constructs that we apply to
it that there are things in the world
that i am a human being
that there are things like nirvana and
reincarnation
these conventional truths are accepted
because they are useful in life it is
useful that i consider you and me to be
different on some level for a fruitful
interaction and it is useful for me to
see myself as distinct from a lion or
i'm probably going to be dead because
i'm not careful in the same way the
teachings of samsara karma and nirvana
are useful for the individual to travel
on the path to enlightenment so to say
in a way we need conventional truth to
help us reach ultimate truth
and what is that ultimate truth then
well at least to nagarjuna it is that
all things are empty
this idea of the two truths theory as
argued for in nagashuna's writings would
continue to be influential on later
thinkers in mahayana buddhism
for example it is on this basis that the
later figures yi founded the tiantai
school of buddhism based on the idea of
a three truths doctrine that's sort of
extension of what nagarjuna is arguing
for here something that we will
definitely dedicate a future episode to
as you might imagine this has only been
a very simple and surface level
introduction to the ideas of nagarjuna
and the madhyamika school but as i said
they are very important for
understanding mahayana buddhism
understanding a lot of the later
traditions in that
in that branch in that school and for
understanding some of the basics of
buddhism and its teachings and history
in general in the future we will explore
more thinkers and movements some that
follow in the footsteps of nagajana and
but also others that are completely not
connected to that tradition at all we're
finally doing some buddhism content here
which is really exciting i know a lot of
you have been asking for some buddhism
here and we're finally doing it which is
so much fun i've been looking forward to
this for a long time
as i said in the beginning buddhism is
incredibly
diverse it's complicated
and it's something that we will try to
tackle from many different angles and
the strategy the idea is that by
understanding major movements and
thinkers within buddhism we will
gradually start to get a broader picture
of what that religion is as a whole
buddhism has an incredibly rich
philosophical and spiritual tradition
that is just an ocean of interesting
stuff to explore which i am very much
looking forward to doing and i hope you
are as excited as i am to continue this
journey of exploring buddhism as well as
all other religions that we're dealing
with here on let's talk religion
so thank you so much for watching thank
you to all of my patrons who support
this channel and keep things rolling i
would not be able to do this without any
of you guys thank you so much and a
special shout out to two of my new
saints fraterji
and ahmed
thank you both so much
if you want to become a patron yourself
then i will leave links to that in the
description it is of course really
helpful for me to continue
bringing you free educational content
here on youtube about the world's
different religions
and i highly appreciate all the support
i can get but also feel free of course
to like the video leave a comment or
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time
[Music]
foreign